opening this weekend shining a spotlight
and launching careers for students to
take the stage The Talented Performing
Arts students at CSN they have a curtain
call Friday and Saturday Lauren negretti
is already Center Stage she's live at
the North Las Vegas campus with a sneak
peek Lauren good morning to you
good morning yes it's going to be a
great show here I've had the pleasure of
seeing them perform it's happening again
Friday Saturday 7 PM Friday 2 p.m
Saturday I'm here with Danny Mendoza you
you are a former student current
instructor as well how did CSN really
prepare you and what opportunities have
you gotten well it prepared me in quite
a few ways it first of all prepared me
to audition for jobs which is very
important and that's what we're also
trying to do here for these young minds
that taught me to choreograph not just
on myself which is what we all like to
do right tick tock and everything we
like to collaborate so we how to work
with people how to you know engage in
conversation not just talking but
movement wise so choreography
improvisation and it taught me to go out
and not be afraid of knock knock on
doors face rejection self-esteem I would
say most of that and you've had a pretty
neat role too you yeah I've had some
roles along here and there my finest job
was Sesame Street Live so I encourage
you guys to travel if you want to travel
the world go ahead and audition for uh
you know touring shows now let's see one
of the performances here you're going to
show us a split fall yeah so what
they've been practicing right now is
called a Martha Graham split fall uh
Martha Graham technique is what I teach
that's what I learned uh studied in New
York City full time and then I came back
here wanted to give them something
tangible and then this is called a split
fall and they're going to go up they're
going to fall dramatically and they're
going to recover
safely
and finish quietly other side and reach
up
they fall dramatically they recover
safely and quietly
and finish thank you so much yes the
safety is definitely a part of that too
that's why that's why I did not attend
that you guys but we are good you can
see them again all happening this
weekend here at CSN live in North Las
Vegas Lauren negretti 8 news now back to
you guys I mean we could dramatically
fall but safely getting back up would be
a different story that's the real
challenge Lauren thank you very much
that's great there's so much talent on
that stage